hey leute und herzlich willkommen zu
einem kleinen best of von meinen ersten
30 minuten spielzeit in rostocks wenn
ihr mehr davon wollte zeigt man mit
einem mag ich und dann würde ich auch
schon sagen jetzt geht's los mit dem
video kommen ich meine wir brauchen kein
motorrad
wir schwimmen einfach das ist wie kommen
genauso schnell voran damon verschwimmen
ist die beste fortbewegungsart wir
verbrennen kalorien stoß in die umwelt
aus ist super wir schwimmen einfach okay
vielleicht wird es ein bisschen
langweilig aber stetig starb jetzt
einfach so ein boot das war nochmal die
idee oder
ok nächster versuch nächster versuch
haben titanic lässt grüßen comcom und
jetzt hoch hoch hoch hoch da kollege
endo das ist verdammt das man sowas von
unspektakulärer ist welches boot ist
cool damals blauen aber das andere
schwarz und mainz habe ich aber ich weiß
nicht ob man es irgendwie total lieb
das ist das was ich in hot stocks mache
ich scheiß auf die story ne das ist das
macht er richtig schön handy in der
tasche
das war toll ich quatsche ok bot nummer
zwei du bist dran hallo klettern ja sehr
schön happig gemeint als mieter ein
spektakel
man will einfach ein sheriff com und wir
sehen dass überall boote am strand
liegen und wird sie ihr verdenken heute
fort worth und ich stehe nur und habt
meine hände hinter aber egal wir
brauchen kein boot denn wir haben unsere
arme mir an der stelle von guten boden
boden rennbooten rennbooten rennboot und
ein boot bleibt stehen bleibt stehen
ja ja nein nein ok fahrt weiter es ist
in ordnung ist in ordnung irgendwie
hassen die mich doch alle oder die fun
immer meine richtung kommen aber ich
wette der bremst nicht mal wir kommen
heute bin ich nicht so drauf ich lass'
ich mal weiterfahren kommen hier vom
alter der bestand aber schnell kommen
wissen füllen wird überbewertet gelaufen
einfach so ein bisschen durch einen
schönen park hier bisschen matsch eine
füße oder wird man direkt wieder ganz
schnell trocken das super ohne spaß hat
das ganze spiel spielt ja irgendwann in
der zukunft ich laufe einfach rum wie
der letzte penner ich habe so eine
scheiß basecap auf die vor 20 jahren mal
in war mein anzug besteht einfach aus
dem leder klumpen das ist unglaublich
eklig geht
ich sehe schon richtig scharf auf mich
rede mit mir
das glaubt oder nicht ich wollte nicht
schießen ich wollte die waffe weg parken
ich habe ich verdrückt
ich gehe da schnell in deckung das doch
einfach keine coolen autos stehen können
wir hier stehen nur solche schrottkarre
das ist nämlich das hauptelement von hot
stocks dass sich hecken kann dass ich
mir sachen angucken kann jetzt bin ich
mich in der kamera die ich mal zu der
kamera und da steht ein wunderschönes
auto und willst du denn hannover mission
is to get that caught in the sims
dorfman alter alles hat sich geändert
ich bin jetzt auf einmal gut ich bin
jetzt keine leute mehr um
ich bringe jetzt keine leute mehr um
warum überlebt er das einfach ok ok
stark jetzt kommt die polizei auf einmal
wird auch gut
das nenne ich doch irgendwie hart wie
ich damit umgehen zu geil
also ich werde die polizei kennt gar
nicht dass ich der böse mensch hier bin
wird erfolgreich ja da seht ihr wie man
toll abtauchen kann und von der polizei
entkommen kann einfach alles umfahren
dass meine bremsspuren quatsch ist der
sonnenuntergang nicht schön gäste wunder
wie so gut nämlich alle an alle ampeln
sind grün
es war äußerst unspektakulär es sind
einfach alle gezielt ineinander gefahren
ich verstecke mich mal sagen ich finde
das ja so krass wenn man mit diesem auto
einfach gas gibt mehr guckt euch mal
anders ist wie als wenn man in so ein
monster truck losfährt
alles fängt an zu wackeln man kriegt
über den boden und nach plastik passt
dadurch gefahr ist da ja ja er war knapp
das diesmal gar nichts passiert das um
entschuldigung tschuldigung björgens ich
will nur meine freundin abholen
entschuldigung ich hasse wieder etwas
über die news haben das ganze leben
macht keinen sinn mehr für mich ich muss
einfach springen
oh mein gott ich dachte wer wasser und
ja immer noch jetzt abgesehen davon dass
das ganze echt schön dass dieses spiel
ist es aber noch am geilsten einfach mit
einem motorrad fährt weil dann kommt
diese jacke mal richtig zum vorschein
dass man wirklich so dass sie sich so
richtig fädelt und so was alles deswegen
ist jetzt mein ziel dass ich mir
irgendwo ein motorrad schnappe hallo
jungs alles klar bei euch dass meine
bank
das sich immer so aus versehen wissen
wenn man einmal mehr aus taste drückt
man direkt die waffe gezogen das ist
unglaublich heftig mal ändern diese
poller hecken was ist denn wenn ich mich
genau auf einen drauf stellt und das
dann hätte ich vor ihr seid ganz
normaler bürger und ihr wollte einfach
her lauf und dann auf einmal
ich hab ein neues motorrad das ist echt
schwieriger als man denkt wo bin ich
denn jetzt hier
09.09.09
allerdings ist das ganze jetzt gegen wie
eine coole rand
ich hätte vielleicht nicht absteigen
sollen die ganzen ampeln ich würde sagen
das war es dann auch mit der ersten
episode watch wenn ihr wollt dass ich
mehr watchdog spiele also ich find das
spiel ist echt geil dafür dass man
wirklich alles hacken kann und so das
ist richtig geil das spiel macht man's
viel spaß wenn ihr wollt dass nicht mehr
davon mache dann zeigt es mir einfach
mit einem markt mit einem markt schreibt
mir die kommentare was ich eventuell
noch alles machen könnte dann würde ich
sagen mach ich die tage noch mal so ein
video einfach den besten zehn
zusammengestellt was euch gefällt zeigt
mir dass gegend weiß ich diebesgut